let's jump to the story from the daily
The Daily Beast and uh you'll get a
little bit more positive I guess
Target removes Pride merch after
right-wing media throws hissy fit let's
see what they call it so uh targets
being boycotted they announced they're
going to be removing their uh a lot of
their pride section hiding a lot of it
but the CEO then says don't worry we're
going to keep our commitment up what
they're basically saying is regular
people have come in and expressed
disdain so then to hide these products
but publicly into the world they're
going to make sure everybody knows
they're still doing it now this is
hilarious Gavin Newsom tweeted this
isn't just a couple stores in the South
there's a systematic attack on the gay
community happening across the country
wake up America this doesn't stop here
you're black you're Asian you're Jewish
you're a woman you're next
so I would just like for everyone to
consider very briefly what gavinism just
said that Target will remove all of
their women's clothing because they
because their patriarchal or something
women can no you can't ShopRite your
target is only for men now well Tim I
mean it makes perfect sense right I mean
there's nothing that people who don't
want sexual perversion forced under
their children hate more than
Asians did The Daily Beast did The Daily
Beast have consider it freaking out when
uh when you had to go to the Supreme
Court to decide if a man could say no I
don't want to endorse your your marriage
of course The Daily Beast didn't freak
out of that but this is this is what
Gavin everything dude was that freaking
out like they said they say Republicans
are freaking out like this isn't the guy
to the Supreme Court that's was that was
that a hissy hold on if it's great if
it's a hissy fit if it's a hissy fit uh
then is it not also a hissy fit to say
oh you don't want sexual perversion
forced under your child you must hate
Asians and black people you must hate
minority like what are you talking about
the history on Earth are you talking
about it was a couple weeks ago in
Nashville when a trans person went and
killed a bunch of Christians right
that's the hissy fit give me a goddamn
break no it was a hissy fit when they
were burning down Minneapolis remember
and store owners were like oh my gosh
how am I ever gonna rebuild and they
were called that a hissy fit yes yes
it's infuriated this is all a big you
know charade of of calling you know
calling us out for when we get upset but
the reality is this is that they've
learned from the Bud Light thing so no I
think I think something happened they
said there were confrontations I think
regular parents that we we don't know
these stories I don't think there's
videos I think regular people walked in
and saw the weird sexualized stuff for
kids and said hey uh what are you doing
I'm not bringing my kids here and so the
left keeps trying to argue that none of
this is inherently sexual when quite
literally LGBT is a reference to a
person's sexual proclivities literally
so when they put that in a display with
children's clothing on it expressing
these ideas
if imagine if they had a bondage section
for for kids not not saying they're
identical these things right some
someone Bolter perversions both are sick
perversions well I'm I'm not saying that
you can say that what I'm saying is
there's a difference but they're both
sexual sexually themed things that in
and of themselves don't directly Show
sex what I mean to say is telling
someone that someone is gay
they're gonna ask a question okay well
then what does that mean it's like okay
well now we're gonna get into the birds
and the bees sure showing someone
bondage gear you say this is just chains
and and silly clothing but what is it
for okay now we're gonna talk about the
birds and the bees actually we're
talking about Kink so in some ways a lot
worse imagine if they put
put items on display which were intended
for use in a sexual context that you
know what I mean like the parents would
be like no that's what the left is
trying to lie about they're saying it's
not inherently sexual then when parents
like we've seen the videos from prod
where the guys wearing The Bugs Bunny
mask and jumping around naked like come
on man well here's the thing if it
wasn't inherently sexual they wouldn't
be so obsessed with trying to force it
onto children and they wouldn't lose
their minds when adults push back
against it because the thing they claim
is being attacked is their sexuality
yeah so here's what I think if this
wasn't sexual it wouldn't be the hill
they were dying on here's what I think
happens I think regular people walk into
Target see it and go kids no we're
leaving yeah like whoa whoa whoa whoa
well here's what here's what really I
was thinking about this today about the
whole thing remember the days when we
just got upset that they were putting
Christmas stuff out like right after
Halloween yeah and now it's like I I
mean I don't even know what is lgbtq
month apparently it's June so this is
why it's out it's coming up guys it's
not even June so they're doing they're
doing the same old it's like well Jen is
actually American greatness month yeah
it's actually the month of the Sacred
Heart uh and then July is Maga month
yeah right yeah but this I mean this is
what's so crazy it's like you're seeing
this and I I think I think it's
mind-blowing to me that people who can't
have kids you know want to exploit
all of the lgbtq community two kids it
like it doesn't even make sense to me I
think they cross the line I think these
corporations they've reached the point
where regular people are just saying we
are not accepting of this we don't care
if you're privately in your own home we
don't care if you want to live your life
and be happy but you started putting on
prominent display in front of our
children you started having people do
sexual things in the streets at these at
these Pride parades which they do you
had uh and I think it was in Florida
they said you can't have grooming you
can't have adult shows for children so
one town canceled their pride parade
what were they intending to show kids at
these Pride parades but but why are they
so obsessed with kids
like there's a whole this play of like
oh we're just trying to open up the eyes
of children that we don't want to have
like the vast majority of any gay couple
that exists doesn't have kids they have
no interest at all and so this isn't a
lifestyle this isn't a simple lifestyle
conversation this is literal straight up
perversion just trying to take advantage
of but but the main point here that I
want to make sure we're on is the the
victory of the boycotts yeah that Bud
Light is reeling and they're not getting
these sales back bud guy was but Bud
Light was trending today to an absurd
degree yep I mean it was hundreds of
thousands of tweets over Bud Light and
their stock has dropped again the stock
for Bud Light is now lower than when it
started this year so there was a period
where I was like it'll go down but it'll
probably go up because all stocks to
typically climb but the the backlash is
getting worse for Bud Light now you've
got North face doing something similar
but they've been doing this for a while
the fact that North Face is on their I
think it's our second year doing this
drag promotion and now people are
getting angry and I'm like I think the
camel's back broke I think regular
people for a long time said well
tolerate it but we don't like it and
then one day they walked their kids into
a Target and saw this stuff and got
angry and they said that's it no none of
it none of it at all yeah well somebody
was explaining the whole distribution
thing to me that part of the reason why
they're seeing the the spike now with
Bud Light is that the Distributors
finally have it's a wave yeah they've or
they've got the max it's just all
sitting there and they're like no more
finally so it's a lagging effect here
the first thing that happens is that
consumers stop buying and then
Distributors don't reorder but if some
of the beer expires they may reorder
yeah now they've got stacks of expired
beer Bud Lights offered to buy it back
yeah they said they will buy back the
expired beer from these Distributors
which is crazy because while the
distributor buy new ones yeah the
distributor is like I'm not I'm not
gonna just have it sit and take up space
it'll go bad again I'm not getting my
money back so you can have it but I'm
buying more so it's a delayed reaction
eventually makes it to the Distributors
who say we're not buying it and then Bud
Light sales get way bad so Target who
knows maybe they won't put out Christmas
stuff at after Halloween I mean it's
it's difficult holiday stuff sure some
people have a holiday gear some you know
when it comes to beer you buy beer
frequently if you drink beer and there's
not really strong brand loyalty so it
was the perfect boycott Target some
places only have Target if you you live
in some suburbs you have nowhere else to
go Target your place yeah if you can
however avoid it I recommend you avoid
it and you're breaking you know these
habits of like my wife you know ends up
in Target four times a week and it's
like now you gotta break that habit so
you know I gotta Geo Tracker and I don't
know shut down the car or something I
mean look look I don't I don't care if
there are people if there are people who
have nowhere else to go I'm I I'm not
going to cry that they go to Target it's
not the same thing as Best Buy so I
think the fact that that targets I'm
sorry as a Bud Light I said Best Buy
I think the fact that they've already
decided to start taking things down
shows that they got impacted outside of
any real conservative boycott I think
regular people started complaining well
someone brought this up today too is
like you know the Target Card you know a
lot of again a lot of wives have a
Target card that's their credit card of
choice yeah just go with your wife and
shut down the Target card that's your
first step so to say hey we're gonna
shut down the Target card tonight should
shut down the Target Card Target cart
the card the card the credit card yeah
oh yeah just get rid of it shut down
your Target card
get that done tonight you can do that in
two seconds just pay it off say I'm
gonna pay it off I'm gonna get you a new
credit card it's gonna be a beautiful
credit card what about Walmart what are
they woke
uh I'm not so I think that the the
founders of the errors were Christian
but I have no idea if that if they're
still you know somebody was mentioning a
good organization I don't know they
found some stuff in Walmart too there
were some posts but they were just kind
of ducking and getting it off the
shelves real quick it was books I think
uh yeah it wouldn't shock me I mean it's
it's also swampy these days but
Walmart's really good about like
really blending with the with the local
community so I'm sure it's more liberal
and more liberal communities and way
more conservative so they'll have like
Christian books up front and like you
know I know in Utah yeah they have
Mormon books up front like I I bet my
guess is it's probably a little bit more
Liberal Liberal communities targets just
like they they push everything the same
yeah interesting so I uh I I just saw
this uh someone from The New York Times
is reporting that when DeSantis was on
with uh Trey Gowdy he finished it up uh
talking about the Federal Reserve and
that he was talking about the Jerome
Powell and as part of his campaign he
intends to blame the fed money printing
for laying groundwork for inflation
which is I mean that should be obvious
and any president that doesn't lay that
out is suspect I mean I I don't know
that Trump would he might sit there and
continue to uh to boast about all the
money printing which is a terrible idea
in my opinion but I personally I find
things that are you know criticism of
the the current monetary policy
compelling personally so
DC Drano hosted a live right now our
Twitter space and uh it's been going
it's been going 50 000 strong for like
like I don't know a long time I don't
know if it's like an hour 55 000 hasn't
dropped at all thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time